( phone ringing )
( woman )
Good morning,
Flower Market.
YES, HELLO, IS
THIS THE FLORIST ?
YES.
YES, MY NAME IS SPOONIE LUV,
FROM UP ABOVE.
I'M TRYING TO SEND SOME FLOWERS
TO A VERY SPECIAL SOMEONE.
IS THAT AVAILABLE ?
YES.
OKAY, UMM, OKAY,
FIRST OF ALL,
I WANNA SEND TWO
DOZEN BLACK ROSES.
WE HAVE-- WE CAN SPECIAL
ORDER BLACK MAGIC.
RIGHT, RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT.
I WANT THE BEST FOR HER.
WHEN DID YOU WANT THEM ?
Because we're gonna have
to special order them.
ALL RIGHT, FORGET ABOUT IT,
JUST GET ME THE REGULAR ROSES.
RED ?
YEAH, GIMME TWO
DOZEN OF THOSE.
Two dozen, red.
RIGHT, AND I WANNA SAY A LITTLE
SOMETHING ON THE CARD FOR HER.
Y'ALL DO THAT, RIGHT ?
YES.
OKAY, COULD
YOU TAKE DOWN--
I'M GONNA COME FROM
THE HEART WITH THIS.
COULD YOU TAKE
THIS DOWN FOR ME ?
YES.
YEAH, JUST LETTING YOU KNOW
LAST NIGHT WAS WONDERFUL.
Got that ?
YES.
OKAY, I NEVER SEEN ANYONE
WORK THAT ASS LIKE YOU DID.
( laughing )
SHE WAS WORKING
IT, TOO, BABY.
THAT'S WHY I SAY WOMEN--
THAT'S WHY I SAY FEMALES ARE
THE EIGHTH WONDER OF THE WORLD.
OKAY, YOU GOT THAT ?
"I NEVER SEEN ANYONE WORK
THAT ASS LIKE YOU DID", RIGHT ?
YEAH, AND WHEN YOUR
SISTER JOINED IN,
IT FULFILLED
MY EVERY FANTASY.
Okay.
TELL HER SHE SCREWS
LIKE A CHAMP.
OKAY.
LET'S DO IT
AGAIN REAL SOON.
You got that ?
UMM...
LIKE TOMORROW.
OKAY.
YOUR LOVE ROCKET,
SPOONIE LUV.
SPOONIE, S-P-O-O-N-E-Y ?
YEAH, SPOONIE LUV, L-U-V.
Could you read that back ?
Could you read all that
back to me please ?
YEAH.
"JUST LETTING YOU KNOW
LAST NIGHT WAS WONDERFUL."
SLOWLY, SLOWLY, SLOWLY.
READ THAT AGAIN TO
ME AGAIN, SLOWLY.
OH, COME ON !
COULD YOU READ IT
SLOWLY FOR ME PLEASE ?
"JUST LETTING YOU KNOW,
LAST NIGHT WAS WONDERFUL.
"I NEVER SEEN ANYONE WORK
THAT ASS LIKE YOU DID.
"WHEN YOUR SISTER JOINED IN,
IT FULFILLED MY EVERY FANTASY.
"TELL HER SHE SCREWS
LIKE A CHAMP.
"LET'S DO IT
AGAIN REAL SOON.
"LIKE TOMORROW.
YOUR LOVE ROCKET,
SPOONIE LUV."
BUT HOW DID THAT SOUND, NICE ?
THAT'S APPROPRIATE, RIGHT ?
That's appropriate.
OH, MAN, OKAY, OKAY--
I MEAN, IF SHE,
YOU KNOW ?
SO WHAT YOU NEED ?
I NEED HER NAME.
UMM, MS. SHAFFER.
M-S ?
YEAH, MS., SHE
WAS MARRIED TWICE.
S-H-A-F-F-E-R ?
AND PUT MS. LAMPKIN DOWN.
MS. ALSO ?
HELLO ?
Yes ?
OH, MAN, EXCUSE ME,
I'M ON THE TOILET, YO.
OKAY.
I'M TRYING TO FIND SOME
TOILET PAPER IN HERE.
OKAY.
COULD YOU JUST READ THAT BACK TO
ME, THAT LETTER, ONE MORE TIME ?
REAL SLOW.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE I
HAVE TO DO THAT AGAIN.
I'VE ALREADY READ
IT TO YOU TWICE.
OH... OKAY,
THANK YOU.
MM-HMM.
ALL RIGHT.